i absolutely love the way that fox news
has framed this story
boxer jake paul
blasts biden for gas prices inflation
claims biden voters are the american
problem i mean in all honesty that's a
brutal statement he said biden
accomplishments highest gas prices worst
inflation plummeting crypto prices that
one made me laugh highest rent prices
ever created new um incomprehensible
language bravo jake paul that was
amazing i don't think he's like a big
conservative dude like he goes after
dana white from the ufc the way he
treats fighters and i i think he's
talked about like unionizing i saw him
do like a either him or his brother
logan did uh like a black lives matter
thing for yeah he's not like a super
like right-wing dude that that's he says
if you're reading this and voted for
biden and you still don't regret it then
you are the american problem
so seeing that after and you hit the
nail on the head he's not like a
conservative guy you don't have i think
we've already seen it with people like
elon musk people who are not
conservative are being like hey i'm kind
of reading the writing on the wall and i
can see how bad this is we had a friend
of mine out recently who's like you know
fairly liberal he was just like man i
don't know i kind of regret this things
are getting really bad yeah so but just
uh just an honorable mention real quick
for them calling him a boxer
and this is another thing people who are
who are not i don't know
four knockouts boxing legends
and this is the thing people who are not
into politic politics are being forced
into politics because of the way of how
extraordinary this great reset is is
going in a way where it's it's just
unavoidable everything now is politics
and it's slowly uh becoming that uh with
every political cycle but i think now
it's becoming more unavoidable than ever
if you
if you don't take an interest in
politics politics will take an interest
in you absolutely plato quote i think
pericles oh okay it's been around since
the greeks oh i thought it was a jake
paul uh
the the thing about tribalism too is i
was thinking about this with
the like the drag shows last week
watching some of my friends on the left
almost feel like they had to defend it
just because like that's what the the
left does and i think
with tribalism in general it should be
so easy like what jake paul is doing
should be the norm right like i remember
when i was against
drone strikes under bush and then obama
who i liked and voted for when he was
doing it too i was like well this is
still bad it's not like well it's a
cooler drone because it's obama it's
still you know so even if you vote for
if you voted for biden or if you're a
democrat you should actually be the most
outraged when something goes wrong and
feel free to call it out and not feel
like oh man i guess i have to defend
biden it's like no you don't dude not if
you don't want to exactly but also this
is an opportunity for for progressives
to be like we told you not to do biden
we told you to do bernie that's so much
better i mean i'm not saying bernie i
think barney would have done better for
sure yeah his mind was there at least
exactly i i i don't know how much better
i think i think things are going really
well under trump i i think bernie kind
of sold out quite a bit i was watching
that lindsey graham bernie thing a
little bit
but i feel like a box is you know a box
of rocks be better than buying it the
bottom was the last thing i think a lot
of liberals wanted and then they doubled
down like it was the greatest thing ever
that was a tough one to watch the whole
i can't stand that guy so i'm voting for
anything else i hope that that never
happens again because it was televised
and it's been recorded now at least we
know what happens it happens every four
years
it's
does it yeah
hillary clinton yeah that 2016 election
was another version of that i think but
people like trump man
you know for a lot of people the the
more bombastic he was the more they
liked him because he was pushing back on
this machine you know i'm glad i finally
just get to admit publicly that he was
hilarious
i wouldn't vote for him but man oh man
was that kind of funny and that was the
craziest thing to me i remember was like
20 17 and 18 i'm just laughing non-stop
at this guy and i'm like people were so
angry and i'm like he's funny the
funniest thing horse face come on when
he yeah this one was so simple but it's
the one that popped me the hardest is
during the democratic debate he
literally just tweeted boring
i was like hell yeah dawg that rules
that's the political commentary i am
here for
that's the reality and then i guess
people just didn't they didn't like the
mean tweets and so they're much they you
know you know what's really funny
actually i'll put it this way there's a
viral meme going around
called donald trump predicted everything
that's happening have you guys seen it
no it's literally just like one trump
rally where trump is like he's gonna
shut down your oil and gas industry
you're gonna see the highest gas prices
there's gonna be a wave of immigrants
coming across the border and i'm like oh
check check check check you know and
this got me thinking too the craziest
thing about it do you guys remember joe
biden said he was going to transition
off gas he was ryan the debate right
right right he's outright and so when i
say you know i said this last week
when you're looking at your gas prices
if you're an environmentalist
anti-climate change person your your
only option is to be like two is to
accept the problem because joe biden
said he wanted to fight climate change
joe biden said he wanted to get off
fossil fuels that's what he's trying to
do here we go okay so that was actually
my question because i remember
the
the people the people liked me last time
i was on the show because i asked
questions instead of just yelling uh
talking point so i legitimately don't
know the answer to this this is gonna
sound like it's a rhetorical well what
do the conservatives want to do but what
do the conservatives want to do like is
there a solution that there because
everyone's furious right but what are
people saying like what would biden have
to do what are people asking to do that
would actually make the prices go down
let me
uh take the non-conservative approach
right away and just talk the rational
approaches we need to start building
nuclear power plants
yes yes yes uh the green new deal needs
to actually be about green energy yeah
so this is like i i'll i'll mention the
conservative stuff in a second but if
the green new deal was like we will
invest x amount of dollars into wind
turbines in these areas we will open up
these areas for geothermal or then i'd
be like well it looks like we got a plan
that all sounds progressive and
wonderful but it's not that's not what's
in it what's in it is like free health
care for marginalized people and like
college and stuff like that and it was a
resolution that never actually proposed
any of the stuff in the first place and
right away i'm just like okay well the
progressive solution should be draft me
draft an actual bill
addressing the expansion of green energy
i suppose what they'll do is they'll say
the build back better bill and i'm going
to be like but that was just so much
that's 5 trillion of random other things
so i will say right off the bat we got
to get off get over this thing with
nuclear power the conservatives are
outright just saying
uh give the permits back for for oil and
gas leases because they shut some down
in the gulf in alaska and on federal
lands
some of these were due to court rulings
challenges by environmentalists not
because biden was doing it biden
ultimately pulled them because of losing
court uh court cases
um what is it um keystone pipeline turn
it back on that'll alleviate some of the
specula speculative pressures oh no i
remember protesting that right exactly
well so this one oops sorry y'all thanks
jamie it's a little more
thanks for shutting it down deregulating
yeah my bullet casings will go elsewhere
conservatives want a removal of certain
regulations that make it harder for oil
and gas exploration yeah so
you know we talk about why why aren't we
seeing more uh oil companies going
certain areas and trying to start
developing more oils because it's
difficult because there's there's
government regulations so the cost
benefit analysis is we shouldn't invest
the money here because it's not going to
pay out in the long run
it is it is it is uh complicated to be
completely honest uh saudi arabia saudi
arabia plays a big role yep because
they're either overproducing or
under-producing which changes things the
the war with ukraine and russia
absolutely plays a big role but
to put it simply
oil exploration
alleviate some of the tensions on
regulation regulations bring these these
uh
allow these leases back on federal lands
if it were donald trump as president he
would convene the ceos of all these
companies immediately he would say tell
me what you need to get the prices down
and then have a plan or just very simply
undo everything that the biden
administration has done because
everything they have done is standing in
the way of businessman is standing in
the way of people being able to fix this
problem with of course regulations taxes
and big government bureaucrats who want
their cut of the middle and are standing
in the way of actual things that could
help the people that could help the
environment but but we're not focusing
on anything so that was my follow-up
question is you know as a table of
people who i think are as suspect of
corporations as we are the government is
by loosening those regulations and
giving more control to the corporations
do we trust them to do the right things
like the oil and gas no they're profit
motive right
so that's the problem there too right
i'd like to see like a focus on
biodiesel and teaching people how to
make biodiesel that's legitimate like
pure and clean that we can regulate and
use but relying on corporations to do it
they're going to have profit motive as
they're there yeah but let's get back to
nuclear a little bit because like
there's a big misperception about modern
nuclear versus like old school nuclear
which is super nasty like this is
actually one of the few things i don't
know if you've seen the bill gates
documentary on nate on netflix one of
the few things that bill gates is
actually invested in which is actually
kind of interesting um this guy's
defending bill gates over here i don't
know
i'm gonna slide my bullet
he's an epstein freak show but his
nuclear power plants are actually really
interesting because the the waste is
extremely minimal i think they're
actually powered by waste and the the
risk of meltdown is just vastly less so
like trump was not talking about nuclear
like no one's talking about they're
they're afraid to talk about nuclear
even though the technology has has
evolved so much
michael shellenberger who's running
against news he just lost he yeah he's
he was the only guy i've heard like talk
about it where i was like oh this makes
sense it was the first time i heard it
yeah he's super smart you can also
confusion is another kind of nucleus you
got fission you got fusion completely
different processes they're both called
nuclear because it's ignorance basically
uh fusion's completely i mean once you
give if if you can ignite fusion and get
it going it basically gives you an
unlimited fuel supply i think that's
that scares people in power yeah jamie i
want to push back on your point here
just a little bit yeah especially when
it comes to the public-private sector
debate especially when it comes to the
larger topic that we're discussing here
discussing here the biden administration
because what we essentially have here is
the government the biden administration
picking and choosing what corporations
are going to prosper which ones are not
so when you look at the green new deal
when you look at all the proposals that
he's pushing it's directly going to
benefit countries that he has business
dealings with with his son like china
especially when they are the ones
getting the the raw minerals to get the
solar panels to get the batteries so
when you look at you know any kind of uh
corporation the most powerful ones the
most unaccountable ones are the ones
that have friends in washington dc
exactly
and my argument that you kind of
countered back on and asked the question
on
you know do we trust these corporations
no obviously but it's because of the
government intervening and and directly
playing a key role in which corporation
does well and which corporation does not
well yeah i agree that last part i don't
trust the corporations either way i
don't trust anybody
but when it comes to the free market and
allowing individuals to choose what they
want giving them choice giving them
decentralization rather than the
monopoly of force government coming in
and saying you can only buy from this
corporation you can only buy solar is
the problem because it leads to more
problems it leads to the government
abusing their power let me let me point
out too that uh
there was a chart i was looking at last
week that shows the trump
administration's last year which showed
inflation and wages were stable and then
a month after uh or like a couple weeks
after biden is inaugurated it inverts
wages collapse inflation skyrockets
it's been a year and a half but it's
still on track going the exact same
direction so certainly by now biden
could have done something so i think the
issue with gas prices too it's not just
about the direct regulations and
policies on gas i know a lot of people
immediately say like what has biden done
directly to effects get get affect gas
prices you can also come out and just be
like
the the unemployment of benefits
expansion which i understand had good
intentions but then you're flooding the
market with the mass release of currency
which is going to devalue the currency
so even if i didn't do anything on this
other on these other issues keystone was
big because that caused massive
speculation if he did nothing other than
the economic policy which results in
inflation
gas will go up along with it because you
got to pay truckers the one of the
things about keystone
that's so brutal is that how do we get
oil shipped if we're not doing it by
pipeline
freighters
trucks that's even worse it takes fuel
to transport you put in a big pipe
there's fears about leaks totally get it
i think the big issue is it's fair to
say we're addicted to oil and i don't
mean that to be a dick but i mean we
built a civilization off of fossil fuels
their fossil fuels are incredible the
the energy return on energy invested is
absolutely amazing and so we were able
to literally create human life
when we build these machines that can
harvest the field faster and better then
all of a sudden people are fat and happy
they're fed they're gonna have babies
they need tons of babies but you're
gonna need that resource to maintain
that level of life as well it freed the
slaves you brought this up a while ago
it was the steam-powered engine in the
industrial revolution the 1800s that
basically gave i mean it was the cotton
gin is the big part of it but
it it opens up the fossil fuels have
opened us up to no longer be slaves to
labor in a lot of ways yup but to what
you were saying luke about biden picking
favorites i mean he won't even mention
elon musk with regards to electric cars
or solar it's like is that one talk
about talk about the players in the
industry yeah yeah you know elon elon
has a low esg score
he has a renewable energy car company
that's a pioneer in its field and again
lots of critical things i could say
about elon but in that particular field
all the green people all or the peacenik
should be all happy and and good
meme with him pool dog exactly exactly
he tweets interesting things now and
he's the main person that that that
pushes the kind of narrative pushes the
conversation and that's why he's the one
that which if you want to strike back
against tribalism that is a moment where
you go you know what i don't agree with
elon musk but he's trying to do
something to help us with our uh energy
addiction i want to do it let's come
together and get people from all sides
to do this thing that shouldn't be
political it's okay to agree with
someone on a single topic you're not
endorsing their entire
life yeah
you know regarding this mass printing of
money i've kind of had a moment of
clarity they're basing it on what's
called modern monetary theory invented
shortly after world war ii i think
thereabouts and the ideas you print as
much as you need to stimulate and to
build your infrastructure so that you
can produce things but what's happening
now is they're using that idea we're
going to print as much as we need so
that fill in the blank they're just
giving it away to people's bank accounts
they're not building the infrastructure
monetary theory needs the special
private interests their buddies in the
upper echelons and the establishments
are getting secret federal reserve
bailouts and they're getting money that
of course makes sure that they never
lose money when they make money their
profits are theirs but when they they
lose money they have losses the federal
reserve literally steps in it's like
yeah we'll cover that for you don't
worry about that yeah that's not a free
market no and it's not modern monetary
theory they're they're calling it that
but it's an aberration of that system
and they're
it's basically just liquidation of the
us no no no no it's the modern largest
transfer of wealth in recorded human
history that's happening right in front
of our eyes it started in 2008 during
the housing market crisis ben bernanke
was literally orchestrating secret
international bailouts of financial
institutions all around the world with
the power of the federal reserve that
literally just went on the computer and
just typed in zero zero zero zero here
you go well here's the money meanwhile
you have to work for it you have to slay
for it you have to work a nine to five
job for it the bankers created the
system zero zero zero zero mine good
luck peasant slave we're going to
devalue the dollar good luck paying for
food this week or this month whatever
the hell it is people are getting
screwed over oily and this is why jake
paul
saying this is so important right now
because it brings this point to a
reality that a lot of people can't
ignore it's not just that it's a
barometer
jake paul coming out and saying it how
many how many more people do you think
are thinking the exact same thing who
are not political people right so it's
like that it's like that joke i think it
was what from simpson to the family or
family guy where they're like we
received seven complaints last night
that means 80 billion people were upset
you know simpsons that's what it was
yeah
well it's like ignoring you know if
you're sick and you ignore your sickness
it's like looking at biden
and how he literally cannot
communicate
and and people are just afraid to
confront that illness that like our
society has if i go to the doctor
they'll tell me that i'm sick and i
don't want to think i'm sick right yeah
but that's on purpose though that i
think that is is made to be a
distraction for the larger agenda that
he is pushing that is directly
benefiting the people who are on the
ship robbing and looting everything for
themselves that the ship is sinking the
ship is the united states it's going
down and there's a lot of criminals out
there that are taking everything they
can for themselves they're not criminals
because they don't adhere to government
law because they're multinational they
don't have a country that they have to
play by the rules of it's got the bank
for international settlements in
switzerland that they're running money
through and they're just siphoning our
wealth it's insane let's let's pull up
this story and then we'll keep going on
that idea so we have this from the wall
street journal s p 500 enters bear
market as dow and nasdaq fall um but i
don't have a savings account i don't
know what any of those words mean
you're screwed help it means bad
it's bad
and i will also point out that one of
the reasons jake paul slammed joe biden
i think the main reason was right there
in the middle his crypto portfolio
probably tanked and he was like
a lot of people bought into crypto and
you know i think it was fantastic i'm
not selling thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 p.m and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you